experienced language learners accept
uncertainty except that they don't fully
understand and yet they keep going hi
there steve coffin here today and today
i want to talk about comprehension
to understand more
don't try to understand too much
and i'll explain but first of all if you
enjoy my uh videos please subscribe
click on the bell for notifications
and if you follow me on a podcast please
leave a review i do appreciate it
so
to i mean listening comprehension
reading comprehension comprehension to
me
is the most important goal in language
learning if we understand well we will
eventually speak well eventually as we
have more opportunity to speak
if we don't understand very well we
can't have meaningful conversations we
can't enjoy movies we can't enjoy books
we can't do all of the things that are
going to improve
our skills in the language
of course we all want to speak well but
we need to speak a lot in order to speak
well but that comprehension is so key
and i know a lot of people struggle with
comprehension so
um i want to give you a hint a tip about
comprehension and that is
don't try too hard to understand in
other words accept the fact that as you
are progressing in the language there
are a lot of times when you are not
going to understand and you still have
to keep going
and don't try to nail down
what it is you're studying say a lesson
except the fact that it's 60 40
comprehension and move on to the next
and i i often mention manfred spitzer
the german neuroscientist who said the
brain needs repetition but the brain
needs
novelty and i was talking to my brother
whom i
gave an ipad to and who's working on
link and he he says i always forget i
study this sentence and i keep on
forgetting and i thought to myself yeah
you're not supposed to try to
totally understand and remember that
sentence you're supposed to just allow
the language to kind of enter your brain
and let the brain get used to it
and so my brother said
it's a bit like mowing a lawn
if the grass is high then you have to
set the lawnmower at a higher level in
order to have an easier
first pass through mowing the lawn the
second time through you can set the
blades a little lower if you try to
force yourself to push that lawnmower
into very high grass
uh you're not gonna get there it's gonna
be very hard work and you won't you
won't be able to get the job done
depending on how long the grass is now
in theory
if you have to mow the lawn twice you
would think it's going to take you twice
as long but if in fact there's just too
much resistance and you can't mow the
lawn you're not going to get the job
done
so it's far easier and i've had this
experience and i'll show you the picture
of my lawn and my lawnmower and how i
adjust it and it's much easier for me
particularly we've had a lot of rain i
haven't been able to mow the lawn
and so when i go in there i have a first
pass at a higher level and then i have a
second pass at a lower level every pass
i pick up a little bit more
it's the same with the content that i
learn from listen to read
first time i go through i don't fully
understand it i may listen a second time
i may move on to other lessons then i
come back and even on something as
basic as the many stories i always pick
up
something the second third fourth time
through so every time i mow that lawn
even i'm flowing through it i'm pushing
the mower through it easily but i'm
getting a few more blades of grass and
on
in that way we will gradually enable our
brains to get used to the language don't
force yourself to try to understand if
you can't understand
move on to new material bringing in new
words bringing in new context some of
which again which you will understand
some of which you won't understand
and i think it's very important that we
have that sort of an attitude i've said
in other videos
experienced language learners accept
uncertainty except that they don't fully
understand and yet they keep going
push yourself forward and then you can
come back again for a second pass with
the lawnmower but i think very often the
the attempt to nail things down to fully
understand is a major obstacle to
comprehension whether it be listening
comprehension or reading comprehension
and the two do reinforce each other as
does the study of vocabulary the goal of
course is to understand
everything or as much as possible
but before we get to that perfectly moan
lawn
we have to make quite a few passes and
so we should be easy on ourselves and
not be too demanding
you know not expect perfect
comprehension and if we keep moving
forward we will eventually
have better comprehension understand
more and if we have good comprehension
we will eventually have good speaking
skills so thank you for listening and i
have spoken before about comprehension
so i'm going to leave a couple of videos
here that i did earlier on the same
subject
bye for now